so this is joe biden's pitch is that his
agenda is free
okay literally he says this he tweeted
out today
my bill blackbutter agenda cost zero
dollars zero
instead of wasting money on tax breaks
loopholes
tax evasions for blake corporations and
wealthy
we can make a once in a generation
investment in working america and it
adds zero dollars to the national debt
okay that's just a lie it's just a lie
it's gonna add zero dollars to the
national debt he's setting in place
programs that are going to have to be
paid for not
annually
not triannually perennially
these programs are permanent this is
what democrats do they set up programs
that are supposedly going to sunset five
ten years from now they never sunset
they only grow these programs are going
to be permanent entitlements in american
life joe biden knows this democrats know
this the notion that we're paying for
this stuff is absolute utter horse crap
it is not true
the build back better agenda costs zero
dollars by the way i love how he
characterizes this when he says instead
of wasting money on tax breaks
okay a tax break is not wasting
it's not your money
it's not your it's not your money
okay that that is like saying
that if i pay back the credit card
company that i'm wasting money
i'm not no it's not my money it's the
credit card companies money
okay in this particular situation the
government is you and the credit card
company is the american people
if the american people get back some of
their money that is not you waste that
is not the state wasting money
that is the state not spending money it
doesn't have
tax breaks are not
the government wasted it wasn't the
government's money didn't come from you
what in the world are you talking about
that's like saying if i steal your
wallet and it has a hundred dollars in
it and i give you 20 back
that somehow i have wasted that 20 it
wasn't my money in the first place i
can't steal your wallet give your money
back and then be like oh yeah by the way
i just wasted money look how generous i
am
you know what'd be better is if i took
that money and invested it and then you
say what are you investing in like the
stock market nope i'm investing it in a
personal entitlement program called a
lease on a ferrari like that is what joe
biden is doing when he says it's an
investment an investment in what
in the growth of the economy no because
he himself is proclaiming that the
economy is going to grow at less than
two percent over the next 10 years
so what exactly is he quote-unquote
investing in and why is it that when
there's an investment typically the way
we refer to an investment is there is an
roi there's a return on the investment
if i invest in the stock market and i
lose 10 percent every single year that's
a that's a crappy investment
but joe biden thinks it's an investment
to blow money on random government
programs why because what is he
investing in he's not investing on
actual financial growth he's not
investing on actual financial return
he's not giving your money back to you
at any point he's not taking your money
and investing it for you the way warren
buffett would he's taking your money
he's blowing it on what he's investing
in is democratic voters
that is the plan the plan is when he
says it's a once-in-a-lifetime
investment he means i'm going to invest
in a bunch of people to vote for me i'm
going to bribe them to vote for me and
for my party until the end of time by
giving them things i'm going to enshrine
in american life more and more
government spending and more and more
government dependency so that you will
keep voting for a larger and larger
government bloat program that reorients
the united states away from free markets
and toward top-down controlled markets
in order to pay for all of this garbage
like that is what joe biden is investing
in he's not investing in growth he's not
investing in a stronger america he's
investing in dependency we all know this
nancy pelosi is doing the same thing by
the way she says
let's not talk about you know things
like money at a time like this money is
what what is money it's just a concept
you know some people use shells
some people some people have used bonds
we use happy dreams and unicorn poop
this will be paid for so when some say
oh well what about inflation it will be
paid for and that's the the beauty of it
by having those in our our economy and
society who have not paid their fair
share paying their fair share so again
the senate and the house those who are
not in full agreement with the
president's rate let's see what our
value let's not talk about numbers let's
and dollars let's talk about values
uh values values yes your value is that
you wish to centralize as much power in
the federal government as humanly
possible and to confiscate money not
just from people who are alive now but
future generations who have not yet been
born
and then use this to buy your own way
into the history books because history
treats very kindly activism government
activism the presidents who are
unbelievably crappy at their jobs get
treated as american heroes so long as
they blow out the spending if your fdr
lbj can be unbelievably crappy at your
job and it does not matter you are
treated as an american hero as a
transformational figure in american life
if you're woodrow wilson until very
recently you were treated as a
transformational hero in american life
specifically because you strayed from
the constitutional limited government
vision of the founding fathers if you're
calvin coolidge you're very bad if
you're orangey harding you're very bad
you know you look in the 1920s in
american life i'm constantly struck by
this if you look at the growth rates in
the united states during the 1920s for
example they're really really really
high right there's a reason that the
1920s were called the roaring 20s then
you look at the 1930s and the 1930s
where i lost a decade in terms of
american growth the 1930s were a garbage
time for the american economy they were
horrific
not just the american economy the world
economy but the american economy
prolonged the great depression by
embracing top-down centralized
government policies courtesy of fdr but
who is considered a good president is it
the president of the 1920s who actually
presided over a booming american economy
is it warren g harding and calvin
coolidge who are considered the good
presidents no they're very bad if you
look at the historical rankings of those
presidents the historians ah those were
do-nothing presidents they didn't do
anything all they did was preside over
massive growth of american
of american economic power
you know as a great president fdr who
presided over america's complete
economic collapse for over a decade that
guy was great you know why because he
installed these programs that we like
ever so much
right the best american presidents
according to the historical crowd are
the presidents who blow out the spending
this is why in 20 years the presidents
who are going to be considered great by
the historians assuming that it's the
same group of people writing the history
books are going to be people like obama
and bill clinton will have been
forgotten doesn't matter that bill
clinton a democrat presided over a
rapidly growing economy in the 1990s
thanks to his moderate economic policy
which he crafted in conjunction with the
republicans barack obama who had the
slowest economic recovery in modern
american history will be will be
considered a great president because he
enshrined big government spending and
joe biden knows this which is why he is
pushing this
okay now there's one problem for joe
biden in all of this and this is he
can't get his own party together and the
reason he can't get his own party
together is because there are people
still like kirsten cinema and joe
manchin are subject to voters who are
not crazy
right there's a bunch of senators who
are in deep blue states where the deep
blue states just feel like we can blow
out the federal budget no matter what
doesn't really matter
but the moderates and progressives are
still very highly divided over a series
of issues so democrats for example
according to the wall street journal are
divided on five key issues they're
divided on health care democrats are
wrestling with funding for and duration
of three central healthcare provisions
an extension of obamacare subsidies
medicare coverage for dental vision and
hearing and an effort to provide
healthcare coverage for some people in
republican-led states that haven't
expanded medicaid so the progressives
who want to expand all of these things
they particularly want to expand
medicare why because bernie sanders has
said for a long time medtech
he doesn't want you per he doesn't want
you to personally purchase supplemental
insurance to medicare instead of
medicare being a baseline insurance
provided to you when you get old instead
medicare is supposed to be a
comprehensive insurance service that is
essentially nhs it's essentially the uk
nationalized healthcare service for old
people and then we'll gradually expand
that backwards in age right that is
bernie sanders pretty open plan he's
pretty obvious about this
pelosi says that all three of these
priorities will be in the final bill but
that could become increasingly
challenging if moderate democrats push
for a lower amount of overall spending
the healthcare puzzles becomes even more
complicated because kirsten cinema and
some centrist lawmakers in the house are
opposed to the democratic proposal to
quote-unquote lower prescription drug
costs by giving medicare the ability to
negotiate drug prices with
pharmaceutical companies
their plan could quote save as much as
500 billion dollars over a decade money
that democrats are counting on to pay
for all of these big spending plans what
they want to do the democrats is they
want to use the federal government in
order to negotiate directly with drug
companies and by negotiating crammed
down on drug companies particular drug
prices and then the quote unquote
savings that we earn from that we are
going to then use on medicare medicaid
aca expansion there's only one problem
with this when you cram down pricing on
drug companies what do you think the
drug companies do all they do is not
provide more drugs
okay patents will be lost
these businesses will be offshored
people will incorporate their businesses
elsewhere there's a reason the vast
majority of medical patents on planet
earth happen in the united states
that drives the economy or it could be
like canada you can live off the fat of
the land trying to negotiate with these
drug companies separately and assume
americans are going to pay the freight
for that and americans pay the freight
by virtue of the higher drug prices but
what they get in response for that but
they get in return for that is that all
these drug companies work for the united
states
hey those are the choices there is no
third choice where they continue to
provide drugs at these at this
government negotiated artificially low
price and then also continue to develop
new drugs that is not the way this works
also the democrats are divided over
long-term home care and child care mr
biden's plan calls for 400 billion
dollars in funding for home health care
for the elderly and disabled
west virginia senator joe manchin has
blocked it spending that much as of
other centres the house energy and
commerce committee drop a 190 billion
expansion plan to help the elderly and
disabled stay in their homes senator bob
casey has his own 250 250 billion dollar
plans a lot of money progressives worry
an insufficiently funded plan won't be
able to achieve its objectives okay well
one of the reasons democrats are pushing
for this is because they are also traded
they're also pushing for home healthcare
workers and child care workers to be
effectively unionized right they want to
treat all of those people as union
employees right this is their goal is
they don't want them to be able to be
treated as individual employees they
want them to be treated as unionized
employees
is a major issue in terms of right to
work
democrats are also divided on climate
the centerpiece of the democrats plan to
address the climate crisis is the clean
electricity performance program which
would pay utilities that switch to clean
energy and penalize those that don't
because clean energy has been such a
boon in places like texas
okay it has not been that is me being
incredibly cynical and sarcastic because
these clean energy programs have
basically just made power
extraordinarily more expensive and less
reliable in most places around the
united states
utilities that increase their use of
clean energy by four percent every year
would get money from the feds those that
failed to do so would get hit with a
fine
but joe manchin comes from west virginia
which is a coal state so he's like nope
not interested in that
meanwhile on immigration democrats are
seeking a path forward after the senate
parliamentarian ruled they could not
include a pathway to citizenship for
millions of illegal immigrants
democrats are still trying to find a way
around all of this
one possibility they've considered is to
update an immigration law known as the
registry which would allow anyone
present in the country earlier than a
certain date to become a legal permanent
resident so basically make daca
permanent
they're also divided on taxes
senior democrats on the senate finance
committee and house ways and means
committee have prepared a long menu of
options to pay for the spending along
with tax credits that will add to the
bill's overall cost progressives and
centrists are divided on a new corporate
tax rate a tax rate anywhere between 21
and 26.5 by the way we are now going to
have a corporate tax rate that is higher
than china's if the democrats get what
they want they want to raise the top
individual tax rate and they want to
include measures to raise taxes on
private equity managers capital gains
and super-sized roth iras used by the
quote-unquote ultra-wealthy
as opposed to everybody else capital
gains apparently no longer apply to
people who are not ultra wealthy which
is weird because it turns out that a
huge percentage of americans own stocks
also the top line cost is at issue so
democrats are divided over all of these
issues and joe biden has no coattails
joe biden has no ability to whip his own
caucus into shape
we'll get to that in just one moment the
reason he has no ability to put his own
caucus into shape is because he refused
to actually govern the way he campaigned
he was always a trojan horse
what he wanted to be as president is not
what the american people wanted him to
be as president he's feeling the pain of
that but it's not stopping him
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit that subscribe button so you stay up
to date with all our future content